[Music]
dude
so fortnite and balenciaga
yeah
collabs
yeah
what do you mean yeah yeah
no i already bought
everything
let's have a look at what's coming in
the mail for me yeah which one did you
get all of it
let's see everyone's talking [ __ ] i
bought literally all yep all that
yeah which one the whole top of it
everything you see it was is it like the
red hat too yeah right there and you buy
that jean jacket too yep
can we just drill into one of the shirts
and just like get a close-up on the
design there
i clicked the red one yeah i'm wearing
this one get a close-up of the
front of it
so you see what they did there yeah it's
500 bucks but you can see why so what
they essentially did is they took the
fortnite logo right they didn't change
it at all no and they put it just right
above the balenciaga logo well it didn't
change that either well it's a cultural
it's a cultural statement this is a
physical representation that fortnight
is is bigger than balenciaga
oh yeah yeah it's it's art man
i see yeah that's what they've done here
they're letting you know the
the cultural significance of fortnite
relative to balenciaga
yeah who is this for
me besides you ninja
you know you know
yeah the next red carpet ninja is on
yeah
he's gonna be rocking this shirt i mean
and him and the wife they love designer
so oh yeah they do there's no reason
that they wouldn't
yeah let's let's have a look at what
else i ordered when she was invited to
the met gala
just wearing this [ __ ] just i mean
anything anything he wore to that would
be incredible
uh that's about to be you go up
the dog of the white hoodie yeah that's
about to be you yeah next episode how
much is the hoodie i forgot how much i
spent
like who's buying this
it's kind of dope actually
730 that's right that's exactly how much
i spent on the hoodie that i purchased
can we have a look at the back imagine
all the fun i had playing that star trek
game
yeah hours of fun
that's what this is worth yeah it's not
but that's they think it is well bro if
let me let me let me put it to you like
this
if there was a balenciaga d and b star
trek collab star trek coin machine
collab
i mean i play the [ __ ] out of that no i
mean like clothing
oh yeah
the dave and buster's logo yeah with
blends they should start doing this with
everything like yeah
buffalo wild wings
yes chili's can you zoom in on the on
the back graphic i want everyone to see
what the back of my hoodie is going to
look like oh it's retail row but in
different languages yeah because again
this is like signifying that
fortnight is an international phenomena
it's a force to be reckoned with madonna
is so jealous that she is nowhere near
the [ __ ] cultural importance of
fortnite
yeah
that's what this hoodie says got it
that's why i paid 730 dollars for
multiples of them multiples yeah really
yeah i had to get all the colors
i got different sizes too just in case i
get smaller or bigger
yeah i just don't know what's going to
happen to me in the future you know yeah
you know how steve jobs wore the same
shirt and pants every day he just had
like different yeah so you have to think
about what he's wearing
that's that's what this is going to be
for you yeah exactly yeah
every single day fortnite maybe it's
yoga
maybe i'll go white large today
or white person
yeah i feel a bit lethargic i'll go i'll
go
white large what does this say though
like what does it say to people that see
you what are you trying to express with
this piece of clothing
um
i'm [ __ ] cool right
i have 730 to blow on
a hoodie and time to play fortnite yeah
yeah
enough to where you're that much of a
fan of it
yeah
i'm trying to let them know like
literally i'm better than you
with these clothes
i'm like like anyone who has this much
money
to spend on this
is cool like either is a full-time video
game person yeah
that makes a [ __ ] ton of money yeah or
they don't have the time to play video
games
bro can you yeah can you imagine
like a bunch of rich kids like the same
kids that go into walmart and demand
their parents get them like
you know at the height of ninjas run
like the parents that went in and were
like mom get me the ninja underwear and
the ninja socks and the ninja t-shirt
and
you know
patented dumple yeah and and you know
the ninja branded blue hair dye right
can you imagine rich kids going with
their parents to balenciaga like mommy i
would like fortnite yeah i want fortune
no that's what i think it's for yeah
it's kids of rich people
yo those glasses go down
i'm so glad i bought these
yeah they're out of stock because i
bought them all paired with the shoes
too oh hard is it the ones that look
like socks
[Laughter]
dude the
the
sock shoe
the shock the shock
nice shot
[Laughter]
i have those
do you yeah they sent them to me maybe
we shouldn't bag on them
no i don't give a [ __ ] they're the worst
how are they comfortable yeah i mean
they're absurdly comfortable yeah but
that's it valenciaga has sent me two
packages nice both times i'm like this
is incredible it's the only designer
brand that
ever has even like contacted me let
alone send me something for free yeah
and one of the times it was this
the second time it was
their nasa backpack
oh well no one gives a [ __ ] about nasa
that's what i'm saying
next week is to be the [ __ ] fortnite
shirt
oh if they did that i'd be [ __ ]
really upset
because i mean maybe matching yeah like
don't send my friends my clothes
okay send me something cool balenciaga
this is my identity please like
the sunglasses for example or those
pants i would wear the [ __ ] out of those
it's so funny that balenciaga is like
like a premier brand and the only reason
they did a nasa backpack is because like
nasa graphics are like
what's the legal thing for like open
source yeah public domain that's the
only reason i use that [ __ ] collabing
with nasa you can buy that this is the
one they sent me [ __ ] dude it actually
would be pretty sick like
like here beside that helmet yeah it
would looks the same as that scroll down
let's let's see something i should bring
it here
how much is it worth
seventeen hundred dollars
i'm selling it
i'm selling it [ __ ]
that dude
seventeen hundred dollars
no dude bring it here no
no come on straight on d-pop
bring it here no we need it
dude we have to see this in person
before you sell it before you put it on
depop bring it here holy [ __ ] who would
ever buy that i need to see this man
that dude that's who buys it
no that guy doesn't even know where he
is
those glasses are just pitch black yeah
he's there's no clue like he doesn't
know what he's wearing he's on yeah put
these on he's gonna look great with that
fit and he's like it's kind of weird are
these supposed to be i can't see
anything then they glue his mouth shut
trust me it's gonna look great with the
fit
[Music]
it'll go away in about an hour just just
shh
look important all right now turn
towards the camera
wrong way but that's actually fire
[Laughter]
that'll be a fortnite scan that guy that
would be sick and he's not able to pick
up any weapons
he just can only look like that
oh yeah you can he can like
do that with the backpack but it does no
damage and he can take no damage
you're just invincible in the game
looking like that and you can't run you
can only walk
or no you just don't always glide i'm
just saying
no it's like he's always like
the controls are always turned 90
degrees so you go forward and he goes to
the right
you're like oh this is so annoying yeah
he's just always sideways turn around
some [ __ ] joe the joe slide just
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] is that just
turning